did you ever meet Lars oh my god I used
to hang out with him until one
disastrous nice when he decided I wasn't
I wasn't up to his partying standard
here's what a large first of all great
guy we would hang out and he's brilliant
that's really pretty so he was like he
was living in New York for a while he's
like Jim let's if you played some clubs
let's let's [ __ ] go downtown wine out
for the night you gonna hang out huh
so we go downtown and playing someplace
down in a village and I find meet him
ride down together and he gets in the
car with me and I find a knapsack a
knapsack and I feel bad because it's an
NYU student he's got all the books oh
this poor bastard kid left dolls please
probably got $200 worth of books let me
hold on to it for the night and I'll
send it to in the morning
well this rubs Lars the wrong way yeah -
why would you [ __ ] carry [ __ ] a
[ __ ] knob cycle you're no fun
so I got this stupid thing it started
slowly yes
slowly irritate him now I see he started
to drink a little and we're still we've
drank before I just never seen the wild
wild side you know we've hung out and
mushed on buses and San Francisco tore
it up but it never really saw this side
so with this club and uh you know having
a drink this kid obviously knows this is
Lars and he comes out to Lars and he's
like excuse me Oh could I can i bum a
cigarette off you Lars turns around he's
a dude he'd ever [ __ ] occurred you
fat sometime tonight before you engaged
in this evening that you'd probably want
to have some cigarettes and you might
not know it but I weren't really [ __ ]
hard why don't you go buy yourself a
backhaul so like and the guys like a
little fan and he's drunk and he's with
some big boys I'm like nah listen listen
it's cool
nah he was like no [ __ ] that
are you so some cigarettes
so am i right let's get out of here well
now this leads to can I see that
knapsack for a second
takes a knapsack down the village it's
Pat Saturday night tosses it across the
street in front of the Comedy Cellar the
thing slams buy some chicks foot it
books scatter all over he's going huh
there's your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ]
irresponsible responsible huh and that
was it no night um so now we start
heading towards 6th Avenue and on a
Saturday night 6th Avenue about 1:00 in
the morning
you can't believe it hey he turns right
in tonight right will [ __ ] hi yes
[ __ ] up we go walking across 6th
Avenue and the light is green he doesn't
stop Hey he keeps walking and cars a
living he's banging the hoods like
before and I I swear to you if they
wrote the scene in a movie you'd go a
little over the top he stepped on the
back of a car walked along the
windshield over the top down on the hood
Superman
beyond Superman I don't know what he was
doing he's hardcore so now he brings me
this a little Club and I'm always been a
starstruck guy so I'm still stuck we
walk in this low private club is
definitely you know walk it's a little
dark 7 2 Avenue streets like I think so
my friends are gonna be here let's go
[ __ ] say hello and it's night right
and we go there it's really dark I was a
little creeped out and I'm I mean you
talk about a billions dollars worth of
entertainers we walk in there's Matt
Damon Ben Affleck Gweneth Paltrow one of
the Backstreet Boys Dave Matthews and
I'm just sitting there going
everybody famous holy [ __ ] knows about
this place where to burn down 90% of
Hollywood - all know where to go and
they and it was just this group in this
little place and it was about 2:00 in
the morning my wife was pregnant with my
first child and I was like I gotta get
home I look at this part I say dude are
you [ __ ] leave right now
are you [ __ ] kid couldn't get him on
the phone after that milieu in other
words you didn't live up I said I got a
go I got it go you're not fun
you didn't party right I didn't fight
you am party I can make it too